[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCES PERRY: So
today we're going
to be talking about Apache
Beam, which is an open source
project that focuses on
batch and streaming big data
processing.
Now there's a technical talk
on Apache Beam later today.
This talk is really about
the growth of the Apache Beam
community.
And in particular, this is
the talk about a journey--
how we went from being
a Google-owned project
into an open
community-driven project
under the umbrella of the
Apache Software Foundation.
Now this transition
drastically changed
the way we work, from
the day to day tooling
that we were using
to the assumptions
that we can make in our code.
And along with the new
community that we're building,
it also drastically
increases the scope
of the things that the
project can accomplish.
So with us today we have four
members of the Beam community
to talk about this journey.
My name is Frances Perry.
I've been an engineer at
Google for a number of years,
working on the technology
that lead into Beam.
And I'm also on the Project
Management Committee for Beam
now.
Tyler Akidau is an
engineer at Google
who primarily focuses on
our internal real-time
and streaming data processing,
internally and in the cloud,
and he's also a PMC member.
Thomas Groh is a Google engineer
and a committer on Beam.
And he works right in
the core of the project,
building sort of the heart of
the Apache Beam abstractions.
And finally, Jesse Anderson
is the managing director
of the Big Data
Institute and also
a committer on Apache Beam.
So we're going to
divide this journey
and the story of this journey
up across the four of us.
So Tyler will start
by introducing
the history of this
technology at Google
and why Google was
interested in donating
this product and this code
base to the Apache Software
Foundation.
Next, Thomas is going to talk
about the transition itself--
how the code had to
adapt to this move
and also how the people
and the engineers
had to adapt to this move.
Jesse will talk about
what attracted him
to the Apache Beam project
and how he got involved
in the growing community.
And then finally, I'll
be back to wrap this up
with a discussion of what's
next for the Beam community
and how you can get involved.
So before we dive
into this, though,
I'd love to get a rough
feel for the background
of the people in this room.
So very quickly, could
you raise your hand
if you're already familiar with
the Apache Software Foundation?
Awesome.
How about the current big data
ecosystem-- so Spark, Flink,
Hadoop--
some?
OK.
And Google Cloud Data Flow--
great.
And when you're interested
in learning more about Beam,
are you interested in
becoming a user of Beam,
either on GCP or elsewhere?
Couple.
And who's interested in
contributing to the Beam
project and joining us?
Excellent.
I'm thrilled to see that.
So I hope that as we talk
through some of this today,
you'll really get a feel for how
important the Beam community is
for this project.
So with that, we're
going to leave
it Tyler to talk about some
of the initial history.
TYLER AKIDAU: Thank you.
All right.
So as Frances said,
I'm going to talk
through a little bit of
the history of Apache
Beam from Google's perspective.
Specifically, I'm going to
give a brief history of four
projects that led up
to the creation of all
the technology that's in Beam.
And I'm also going to talk
through Google's motivation
for being a part of the creation
of the Beam project itself.
So first up, a brief history
of data processing at Google--
so our journey with large
scale data processing
began with MapReduce
back in 2003.
So before MapReduce,
anyone within Google,
or without really, who wanted
to perform large scale data
processing had to
create a custom system.
This custom system
consisted of two things.
It consisted of the
data processing logic--
so the actual code that
described the type data
processing you
wanted to perform--
as well as this complicated
set of distributed systems
logic to give you the
scalability and fault
tolerance over unreliable
machines that you needed.
And this was a real
hassle, because everybody
was constantly rebuilding
these custom systems
and dealing with both
their data processing
logic and their
distributing systems logic.
And so what the folks who
created MapReduce realized
was, if we could
split those two apart,
it would make
lives a lot easier.
And so that's what
MapReduce did.
It really provided a simple
API for describing your data
processing logic.
And then that was coupled
with a scalable fault tolerant
execution engine for running it.
And this was very
successful at Google.
And we thought it was so
great that we really wanted
to share it with the world.
So we wrote a paper.
As MapReduce continued to
be successful within Google,
some common patterns evolved.
People wanted to solve more
complex data processing
problems than you could express
with just a single MapReduce,
so they would write large
pipelines of MapReduces.
You'd have these sequences
and trees of MapReduces.
And since they had all
these MapReduces lined up
that needed to be
run, everybody started
writing custom systems to
orchestrate the execution
of these MapReduces.
And additionally, to make
these run really well--
really perform it
really efficiently,
they started hand
tuning the code.
So they'd take this
nice, clean logical code
that they'd written, and they'd
start pulling pieces of it
out into other MapReduces
and performing these hand
optimizations that
would obfuscate what
the actual logic
was supposed to be,
but make the
MapReduces run faster.
So FlumeJava aimed
to change that.
And it did so in three ways.
One is that it expanded
the API for MapReduce
and generalized
it into something
that could express an
arbitrarily complex and large
pipeline in a
clean, clear manner.
Additionally, it was able to
take this clearly expressed
pipeline and optimize
it under the covers
and come up with an efficient
and performant execution
plan for actually running
this thing on real hardware.
And then additionally,
it provided orchestration
of these various MapReduces
that were actually
the physical
representation of the code
that users had written.
And as before, this
worked out really well.
It was very successful
Google, and we desperately
wanted to share it
with the outside world.
So we wrote a paper.
Around the same time,
there was a class
of problems that were being
solved with MapReduce and Flume
but weren't really
being served well by it.
These were the types
of problems that
dealt with unbounded data-- so
essentially, infinite streaming
data sets that needed to
be processed continuously--
and also typically
really benefited
from providing low latency
results-- so getting answers
quickly.
And so the MillWheel
project was created
to try to address
those use cases.
And what it brought to the table
was a true streaming engine
that could operate on the
level of record by record.
So as data flow
in, one record at
a time, it could process it
and give you your results.
And in doing so, this was able
to provide those low latency
results that folks were wanting
over unbounded data sets.
But it also did so without
compromising correctness.
And this was even
in light of things
like machine failures,
fault tolerance,
and out of order data.
And as before-- as the trend
you've probably seen so far--
we really wanted to share this
with the rest of the world.
So again, we wrote a paper.
So finally, having built
these three systems,
we looked back at what
we'd done and said,
we've got these three
systems that touch
different aspects of the area.
It would be really nice if we
took all of the great ideas
from those and combined them
together into one system.
And so that's what
Cloud Dataflow was.
And Cloud Dataflow really is
two things at a high level.
It's this combined,
unified batch
plus streaming programming model
and SDKs for actually writing
these pipelines, as well as
a fully managed execution
engine for running them.
And as our history
has shown, we would
love to share this with
the rest of the world.
But we finally got it right.
And we finally shared it,
the full system itself.
And that's what
Cloud Dataflow is.
So you can take this SDK and
download it, write pipelines
with it, ship them off
to the cloud service,
and it will be executed for
you, which is fantastic.
And just for good measure, we
also wrote a paper about it.
So that's a history of all these
systems that led up to Beam.
But where does Beam fit
into the picture here?
Well, like I said,
Google Cloud Dataflow
is really these two things.
It's this programming model and
SDKs for writing your pipelines
and this managed service
for executing them.
So when Google, along
with a few partners--
Talend, Data Artisans,
Cloudera, others--
decided about a year ago
to create Apache Beam,
really what we did was we took
the programming model in SDK
and donated that to the
Apache Software Foundation.
That's what became Apache Beam.
And Google Cloud Dataflow itself
remains this managed service
for executing Apache
Beam pipelines.
And yes, just to be clear, Batch
plus Streaming equals Beam.
That's where the name came from.
But what were the
motivations behind Beam?
Well, there are really four
that are worth touching on here.
One is the technology.
All along, we've loved this idea
of sharing awesome technology
with the rest of the world.
And that's part of the joy
of open source software
is truly being able to share
not just the technology,
but everything that
creates that technology.
And that leads then
to communities,
which is the second, and perhaps
most important, part of this
is instead of just being
this project that's
built within Google with
whatever resources Google is
able to throw at it, with
whatever ideas Googlers may
have, now it's
developed externally
with the rest of the
world, incorporating
a diversity of ideas.
We can basically
enlarge the number
of people that are
actively working on it
and really push forward the
state of the art in ways
that it never could otherwise.
Just look at the amazing
diversity within the Apache
Hadoop ecosystem and
what's happened there.
Thirdly is the
portability aspect.
We really think that
Beam has a chance
to be the programmatic
equivalent of what SQL is
to declarative data processing.
So you can write your
pipeline once in Beam.
And then you can choose to
run it wherever makes sense.
You can choose to
run it on Spark.
Or you can run it
on Flink, or you
can run it on Cloud Dataflow.
The core concepts are the same.
And also, it's a chance for
us to draw a line in the sand
and not just give you a lowest
common denominator of what you
could write for a
pipeline, but really say,
this is the state of the art,
this is what things should be,
and then try to help ensure
that runners everywhere
move up to that high standard.
And lastly, of course, there's
a business reason for Google
for participating in Beam.
The more people we have
running Beam pipelines,
the more people
there are that might
want to run it on Google Cloud.
And our goal as Cloud
Dataflow developers
is to make Dataflow
the absolute best
place to run Beam pipelines.
But then wearing our
Beam hats, we just
want to make sure that
Beam is the absolute best
way to write pipelines
in general, no matter
where you run them.
So with that, I've talked about
the history and the motivations
behind Beam.
So I'm going to hand
off to Thomas now.
And he's going to
talk a little bit
about the mechanics of bringing
the Beam project to life.
THOMAS GROH: Thank you.
So like Tyler said,
I'm going to be talking
about how we took the the
Java SDK for Cloud Dataflow
and taken that and our
development process
and moved all of this to the
Beam project and the Apache
Software Foundation
and what that's
changed with how we
develop and the process
and what we've actually had to
implement to make that happen.
So I'm going to start at
the first Beam pull request.
So this is taking all of the
SDK for Java for Dataflow
and dropping it into
the Beam repository.
And as you may be
able to tell, we
came here with a
bit of history--
more than 1,500 commits.
We're adding
165,000 [INAUDIBLE].
And this is all after
we've taken a lot of effort
to tease out a lot of the
Dataflow-specific parts
of the system.
But that's not all.
We still need to
integrate runners
that are provided
by Cloudera and data
artisans for Spark and Flink.
We still need to reorganize
all of our directories,
because we built in a lot of
platform-specific assumptions
when we think we're always
going to be running on TCP.
And we need to just get
Dataflow out of the name.
It's everywhere.
It's in all our packages.
It's in all our namespaces.
And we need to move
that, put it in Beam.
And these are all pretty
significant backward
compatible changes.
So anyone who's jumping ship
immediately is going to break.
And while we're doing
all of these changes
and we're breaking all
of our current users
who are trying to jump ship
and we're moving everything
to Beam, we're
also, as engineers,
parachuting into this new
distributed community.
And when you're working
in distributed community,
it's very, very different than
working in a local community.
When you're working locally,
you can wander 10 desks down,
grab a coworker,
grab a whiteboard,
and just go at it
until both of you
agree on what
you're trying to do.
When you're in a
distributed community
and the person is
10 time zones away,
that's basically impossible.
So we've had to develop a new
kind of distributive process
that includes this whole
set of contributors
and puts everyone
on equal footing.
And that's meant we
put a lot of work
into working on the
mailing list first.
If you're not working
on the mailing list,
you're not really working.
It doesn't really count.
And that's built
a lot of process
where we have documentation.
We built designs, and
we proposed designs.
And then months
or years later, we
can look back at those
designs and we can say, well,
why did we do this?
What was the context?
And we can pull all
of that back out.
But all of the stuff we
dropped and we contributed
has a lot of that
history behind it.
And as a result, it's
really difficult for us
to say, well, why
did we do this,
because that's all
from years and years
of internal experience.
So it's not really easy
for us to share it.
So we've combated this
by writing blog posts.
We've taken things we've
determined internally
like style guides and
our design principles,
and we brought those to
the community and said,
here, we have
experience doing this.
We think these are great.
And then we've worked
with the community
to publish that kind of design
principles and those style
guides alongside
some of the more
mechanical parts
of contribution,
like here's how I
push code, here's
how I think about
the code I'm writing.
But now we've got a mailing
list and a community
and a repository.
And the repository's
filled with code.
But all that code is
really mostly still
just the Dataflow SDK for Java.
And the vision of Beam is
that we have a single model.
And that model works
across languages.
And that model is extensible.
And it's a platform for
other people to build on.
But when we have just
the Dataflow SDK,
that's not so much the case.
So when we want to say, well,
we've got this Beam model,
then we need to
really codify, well,
what is the Beam model really?
And we've done this
by building a couple
of new things like
the Runner API
and the Fun API, which are kind
of an extensible core which
you can build new
SDKs on and which
you can build new runners on.
And they're the extension points
for what Beam as a project is.
It's not just a
single implementation
of our programming model.
It's the model.
And all of these implementations
build on top of that.
And then we've got a vision.
And we've got our code base.
And we've got all these
features that we're developing.
And we've got a
bunch of contributors
who've managed to start
building on top of this.
But beyond that, when you've
got a repository and all
these cool ideas in it,
what you've really got
is a bunch of text
files in a repository.
And they might be
impressive text files,
but they're still
just text files.
So we've built
the infrastructure
to enable these contributors
to go, write test, build
their code, run
their code, and try
to make sure the community
gets access to everything
at every point in this process.
Designs go on the mailing list.
And the community reviews them.
Code goes on GitHub, and
the community reviews it.
And then we've also
brought along the culture
of testing and making sure we
know what our code is doing
and what's happening.
And then because Beam is
this thing that we don't just
want to run, but we
want it to run well
and we want it to
get better over time,
and we're in the
process right now
of building benchmarking tools
and performance testing tools,
again, for the entire community.
So it's, again, not one
implementation, but all of us.
And with this infrastructure
and this extensible platform,
we've seen a lot of
contribution from the community
and new people getting
involved and adding things
like I/O connectors, adding new
runners, adding new libraries.
And the runner authors
have been really valuable,
because runners are doing a lot
of development by themselves.
They're saying, we've
got this cool new idea.
We're going to bring it in.
And then they come to
us on the mailing list.
And they're like, we're
trying to do this.
Why don't we put
it in the model?
And what that means is
that we're all together,
getting better, not
just individually
we've got this cool new thing
and it only works on Spark,
or it only works on Flink,
or it only works on Dataflow.
We're saying, build it once.
Run it anywhere.
It's just going to
get better over time.
And then we've just also
got a diverse community
who has their own perspectives.
They see how Beam is used,
how they want to use Beam,
and they bring it back.
And they say, well,
I want to contribute.
I want to do the thing.
And it's very exciting to see
new people come in and say,
I've got this great idea.
I'm trying to get this
new thing to work here.
I want to work with
you and develop that.
And Jesse has been with
us for a pretty long time.
And he's one of these
community members who come in
and said, well, here's
how I see Beam being used.
And I'm going to
give you to him now.
JESSE ANDERSON: So why
was I looking for Beam
before I knew about it?
When Frances was asking of
you about why you're here,
hopefully you're thinking
about the same things
and you're seeing some
of the same things
that I am, because I
teach pretty extensively.
And I was seeing some issues
out in the big data community
that I was looking
for a solution.
So there is a picture of me.
You can see that I
have a new body now.
It's kind of like "Futurama."
But there I have that new body.
And that was me walking
around Strata San Jose 2016--
about a year ago--
asking everybody I knew that
I was saying, I'm seeing this.
I'm seeing this.
And I'll go through the
things that I was seeing.
But I was really trying
to find a solution.
I'm seeing these issues.
And you're probably seeing
those issues right now.
And then I bumped into
this guy at Google
named William Vambenepe.
And I said to William,
everyone's having to rewrite.
How many of you are
sick of rewriting
every time you went
from maybe MapReduce
or you went from one
framework to another?
Are you tired of that?
I know I am.
This is absolute
waste of our time.
And then I don't know
about you, but since I
trained in big data,
I have to learn
every single one of these APIs.
There's value for
me to doing that.
There isn't value
for you to do that.
You trying to learn every single
one of these new APIs that
don't work with each
other, that's a big issue.
That's a total
waste of your time.
And then I put my CTO hat
on-- hopefully you got enough
of that during the keynotes
today of CTO speak--
well, here's my CTO speak.
Guess what?
Some of these projects
are going to die.
There is not enough room
for all these frameworks
to completely live.
There is not enough
market share.
Inevitably, we're already seeing
some of these products dying.
And you know what's
going to happen?
Those companies are going
to be stuck in the lurch.
They're either going to have
to prop that product up,
or they're going to
have to move again.
And guess what?
When you make that case to
your CTO or your manager
and you say, oh,
guess what, we just
rewrote to this one last
year, that project died.
We're going to have
to go over here.
Those are not the
kind of conversations
you want to have with your CTO.
So I said, what
are people doing,
because I knew I
was going around.
Everybody was
saying, I don't know.
I'm seeing these things, too.
Or they may have
been seeing them.
And then William
said, Apache Beam.
And I said, OK,
well, what's that?
Give me some more information.
And there we have it.
So here's what I want you to
take away from this session.
If we're learning
framework-specific APIs,
every time a new
framework comes out,
we have to completely change.
And they completely
change their existing API.
That doesn't create
any value at all.
Have you ever seen
an SEC filing where
somebody said, hey, we moved
from MapReduce over to Apache
Spark.
You ever seen an SEC
filing that says that?
No.
Companies do not care about
what framework you are using.
They care about what business
value you're creating.
And if we can have a
system like Beam that
allows you to create that
business value faster,
better, not having to rewrite
code all the time, guess what?
It's a total waste of
your time to do rewrites.
It's a total waste
of your time to learn
all these new framework APIs.
There's just a whole
bunch of problems there.
So it looks like a lot of you
were familiar with the big data
ecosystem.
And this is a diagram I
often share of the big data
ecosystem.
So looking at this, we see
all sorts of different things.
We see Real-Time clusters.
We see Pub/Sub clusters.
We see Real-Time SQL
clusters, Hadoop clusters,
NoSQL clusters.
And you see all these edge
things around consuming them,
working with them.
So here's the problem with this.
How many different APIs
do you see on this slide?
There's 20, maybe 30
different APIs on this slide.
And you know what's the
fun kicker about this?
The API for that
Real-Time cluster
to reach into that Pub/Sub
cluster is actually different.
So there's an API that
that Pub/Sub cluster has
when you directly access it.
Oh, and then there's a brand
new API when, let's say,
Apache Spark accesses
Apache Kafka.
That's a brand
new separate API--
separate one you have to learn.
Who's excited about this?
Lots of learning, lots
of value being created.
So these are some of the
things that I was seeing.
Here is a visualization of this
where we're looking at this
and we're saying,
oh, my goodness,
there are way too
many different APIs,
way too many different
abstractions in these APIs.
Wouldn't it be great
if we had something
that could allow us
to go through these--
not have to learn
every single one?
So let me talk about
why I personally
am excited about Beam.
And this leads into my journey
of becoming a committer.
But I want you to understand,
and hopefully as you're
sitting here, this is
why I put the effort,
I put my time into it
to become a committer.
And hopefully, these are
issues that you're seeing now
or will see in the
future that I think
Beam is correcting and fixing.
One of them-- the
slide we just saw--
we saw 20 or 30 different APIs.
You know how many APIs you'd
have to learn with Beam?
One.
We've got one API
to rule them all.
There we go.
Just one API to learn.
And you can deploy that
API onto Apache Spark.
You can do that on the Dataflow.
Another big one-- so
putting my CTO hat back on,
I can move between
frameworks now.
You don't know
how important that
is until you've ever had to move
frameworks and do a reroute.
That's actually
pretty important to be
able to sell this internally.
If you're going to
say, by the way,
we just finished that
Apache Spark rewrite,
or whatever rewrite we did,
and now when we go to Flink,
we're going to have
to do another rewrite,
I don't really want to do that.
We'll obviously have to retest.
We'd have to QA, perf
test-- all that fun stuff.
But it ideally won't be a bunch
of development time involved
in that.
Out of curiosity,
how many of you
are familiar with Spark
Streaming and Spark APIs?
So hopefully, you've looked at
that from an API point of view.
Beam is actually
the most unified API
I've seen, in terms
of batch and stream.
If you've worked with the
streaming API and the batch
API, they're somewhat similar.
But they're different
enough where you actually
have to learn--
I just wrote a class on this--
you actually have to
learn, here are the nuances
to the streaming API.
Here are the nuances
to the batch API.
It's actually not as coherent
and not as similar in API
as you'd like to think.
And that's a big issue, because
we would ideally want something
like Beam, as Tyler showed.
It's Beam.
It's batch, and it's streaming.
And when you start to
go through that API,
you'll actually see, oh, OK,
this is how they do that.
I don't have to write very
different code for my streaming
versus by my batch analytics.
Another one-- unified
API to all the ecosystem.
So that slide that
I showed before,
if we were to do that
with Beam, we'd have one
API into Kafka, whether
we're running on Spark.
Whether we're running on this
or that, it's that single API.
Or if you're going to go into
some other ecosystem project,
it's all that single API.
And that's where a
lot of our effort's
going into in the project.
Once again, CTO hat on--
that risk mitigation,
it's very, very important.
If you're going to talk
to your suits back at work
and say, hey, I
heard about Beam,
you talk about risk
mitigation of not
putting all our eggs in one
basket and being able to move.
And then they'll
understand it much better.
So these are some ways in
which I've contributed.
If these are helpful to
you, I won't go into them
in great depth.
I wrote some positioning pieces.
Once again, if you back
to work and you say, hey--
the suits and you talk
to the suits once more,
and you want a
positioning piece of this
is why somebody should
actually be looking at Beam
or a company should be looking
at Beam, you can go there.
I've written two
pieces on positioning.
I also brought some
extensive point of view
from training
where I've actually
written a class on Apache Beam.
I've done some pretty
significant evangelism on Beam.
Tyler and I spoke
at Strata New York.
I'll be going to QCon Sao Paulo
later on, talking about Beam,
talking to people about Beam.
If you want to see
some code, this talk
will obviously be
pretty devoid of code.
But there are some
more example code.
If you go to that link, it
will send you on to my GitHub.
And then there is
the interacting
with a team as a non-Googler.
So this is an interesting
point of view.
That's why they put
the token non-Googler
up here on the
stage, because they
wanted you to hear from
somebody who isn't from Google.
So ideally, you won't think I've
drank Kool-Aid or something.
And so what do I do?
Why do I like the team?
What's it like
interacting with the team?
They're over there, so
I'll kind of go like this
so I can't see them.
But what are they
like to interact with?
And I actually really enjoy
interacting with the Beam Team
where we've all gotten
along very well.
It's actually been a great
journey to talk about.
So I'm actually going
to talk about that
with my first commit.
So if you're thinking that
from maybe a little bit
of trepidation or
maybe, I don't know
about interacting
with them, that's
kind of how I started that.
I was like, all right,
let me dig into this.
Let me throw out something.
Let me try some
code and see what
that's like,
because I personally
have contributed to several
different open source projects.
I've contributed to Hadoop.
I've contributed to HBase--
quite a few-- even Kafka.
So here's a commit.
This is my first commit that I
added some type descriptors in.
And it was pretty simple thing.
But it was something
that I saw in the API
that hey, this is really good.
This would be something that
would be interesting to add in.
It's going to save
some lines of code.
It's going to save some
conceptual overhead
of trying to understand Beam.
So those three lightning
bolts was boom,
that the interactions
with the Beam
Team-- if you want
to go and read those,
it's some good bedtime reading
to read GitHub interactions
about, pushes and pulls.
And then Ken from the Beam Team
said, hey, looks good to me,
I'm going to merge this.
That was my first commit.
It was pretty painless actually.
If you've ever done a pull or
a push into-- a pull request
into GitHub--
it's not too bad.
It's not terrible.
So when Frances was talking
about, hey, find either a JIRA
or find something--
look in the API.
I saw a few people
with your hands
up that your Dataflow SDK users.
Maybe there is
something you'd say,
there was always
something I really
wish was part of Dataflow SDK.
Well, on the Beam
side, we've actually
had some people come in and say,
there is this thing I wanted.
Boom, there's the
push that they did.
And they said, here,
I've already written this
and contributed it.
So eventually, I
became a committer.
And this is the
actual announcement.
I was one of the
first committers.
And you can see that
they're at the bottom.
There's Thomas.
Thomas was made a committer
at the same time as me.
So that wasn't a
significant amount of time.
But it was an amount of effort.
It was an amount of
effort that I decided
and I realized, yes,
this is something
I actually want to do.
This is something
that I see Beam
doing what I want it to do.
So going back to that initial
talk that I had with William,
some of the things that
stuck out to me about Beam
that I hadn't heard before is
that it wasn't somebody's idea,
it wasn't somebody's theory,
and it wasn't somebody's PhD
thesis.
This was code running
in production.
There's a very big
difference between that.
If you're coming from
the open source community
and you've seen
some of that, you
might have seen
somebody's PhD thesis
and tried to use
that in production.
You're sitting down.
You may fall down otherwise.
PhD theses don't [INAUDIBLE]
well in production.
Oh, my goodness, it happens.
But here, what we have
is we have real code.
As Thomas showed,
there was a lot of code
that was contributed.
It was mature code.
It was code running production.
And I thought, OK, this
is exactly what I can do.
I can get behind a project
that's really getting started.
It actually has
some miles on it.
It's proven in production.
There are some other
things around it
that we're going to
expand on and improve on.
But the core of it-- the
really, really hard parts--
are pretty much done, and
they're pretty much proven.
So when you look at products
and projects out there,
that's a really important thing
to look at in open source is,
is there miles on it production?
Are there people using it?
That's a good metric when you
put your CTO hat on and say,
should I use this
technology or not?
So here's a graph that
I wanted to show you.
And the thing I like about
this graph is a few things.
So the blue line is Google.
So these are contributions
to, now, Apache Beam,
to the left of the incubation
period, Dataflow SDK.
So to the left of that, we
have the pre-incubation period,
mostly Google.
But now what we're seeing
is after the Apache donation
there on the right side
of that yellow line,
we're seeing a
significant uptick.
And these are unique
contributors per month.
So I'm obviously one
of those contributors.
I usually try to contribute
something at least
every month, if not more.
And so what we're seeing
here is a significant uptick
of people like you.
It really warmed my heart
to actually look out and see
how many of you
said, I'm looking
to become a contributor.
If you didn't see me,
I clapped, because I
would love to see
you all participate,
because it's a great
community to be in.
And what we're seeing
is the manifestation
of a great community.
Actually, hey, there's
a chart for that.
And this chart is showing
we've got some upticks in terms
of people contributing, people
continuing to contribute,
people actually
creating things that are
very interesting about them.
So here we have
this gradual uptick.
And that uptick is
obviously not from Google.
And we also have Google
continuing to contribute.
So that's really
some of the things
that I look for
in open source is,
is there a commercial
company behind it
with a vested interest?
As he talked about, Google
does have a vested interest.
And that's what
Tyler talked about--
that Google has
that vested interest
in continuing to promote
this, continuing to run this.
And then there's
other people like me
who have a vested interest
in building Beam and making
Beam something even better.
So I wanted to
give you some code,
just in case you got bored
and were looking for code.
There's this thing.
If you've ever been
to big data summits
or looked at big
data technologies,
there's word count.
Well, there's also
this other thing of,
how small can you
make your word count?
So I actually wrote
some word counts.
And I said, this word
count is too big.
And it was like the "Goldilocks
and the Three Bears."
So I made word count
a little bit smaller,
and then I made it as
small as I possibly could.
So this is actually word count.
This is a word count that
you could run right there
on Google Cloud Dataflow.
This word count is pretty small.
These are actually
a few of the commits
that I've done personally.
The regex-- I don't
know if you've ever
done a regular expression
in, let's say, Spark code.
More than likely, you
did it inefficiently.
Let me just tell you that.
If you don't know what
I'm talking about,
come out to me afterward and
I'll tell you exactly why.
But more than likely,
you did not [INAUDIBLE]
incredibly inefficiently.
So I created one.
I said, here's an efficient
one, because we often
do regular expressions.
And then we have our count.
And then there's this
other two string.
So now we have a built-in way
of taking whatever object you
have--
let's save out the strings of
it and write that to the file.
So these are just some examples.
These are obviously
pretty simple examples.
But these are some
examples I hope
to hold out to you as, this
is how you personally could
start contributing to Beam.
If you're already
a Dataflow SDK user
or you're looking through
the API and saying,
hey, I'd really love
to see something
like this or something like
that in Beam, you can do it.
You can do it.
You can actually go through.
You could look at some
of my previous commits,
see that they're interesting.
So now we're going to hand
it back over to Frances.
She's going to talk about
what's next for Beam.
FRANCES PERRY: Thanks, Jesse.
All right.
So I wanted to talk a
little bit about the state
of the project, where we're
at, what Beam's next steps are.
So I think many of you who
know the Apache Software
Foundation know
that projects start
in a phase called incubation.
This is basically a
bootstrapping phase
where the project
is showing that it
can act in the Apache way.
The Apache way is very
much community before code.
You're building an
open meritocracy where
anyone can come and develop.
So Beam graduated-- oops,
those went the wrong way.
There we go.
So Beam graduated
in December, which
basically is a statement about
the health of the project.
So Beam is now a top level
project at the Apache Software
Foundation moving forwards.
And along with that
great community
that we've built, though, we
really need a solid technology.
So one of the large
focuses going forward
is this portability
structure and infrastructure
that Thomas alluded to.
This is what lets users mix
and match the different SDKs
and the runners so they can
really choose the language that
meets their needs in
the runtime environment
that they're currently after.
One of the other
things we're doing
is continuing to treat
Beam as the glue that
integrates other projects.
So we'll be adding support for
additional storage formats,
new DSLs that let you write
Beam-style pipelines in maybe
SQL, Scala.
There's a lot of work out
there, because again, people
want to be able to use the
technology and the power
it brings in the environment
that's familiar to them.
And finally, one of the
things we're committed to
is clear promises about
backwards and compatible API
changes.
We've all seen what a pain it
is when the API you're using
is constantly
changing underfoot.
So the Beam project is moving
towards its first stable
release where we'll be
able to use Sem Versioning
and make some very
clear promises.
So those discussions are
underway on the mailing list
right now.
Looking like maybe
early April, we'll
hit that milestone
as a community.
Now again, all this
technology that we're doing
needs a diverse
and open community.
And so I really encourage you to
come and start looking at Beam
and what we've got to offer.
So you can go to our website.
We've got a very active user and
dev mailing list you can join.
The website has a lot of
information, podcasts,
articles, videos
about the Beam model
that you can learn
in more detail.
There's a Quick Start.
So if you've got a Flink cluster
in your back pocket right now
and you'd like to
run Beam on it,
we've got a Quick Start
to help you do that.
And we have JIRA issues.
Some of them are
tag with Starter.
So feel free to find
an issue that you
think you could tackle and
dive in and start contributing.
We really welcome new
voices in the community.
You'll find if you
post a welcome message
and just introduce
yourself, you'll
get a huge bunch of people just
plus oneing that, welcoming
you to join us.
Later in the afternoon,
in a couple hours,
there's another talk
on Beam that I'll
be giving that focuses
more on the technology.
So there, what I'll do is
introduce more of the details
behind this unified
model and how that works
and also give a demo of the
same Beam pipeline running
on Cloud Dataflow, Apache
Spark, and Apache Flink
to show you that this
portability that we're
building out is really
coming to fruition.
So with that, I think I'll
invite the other presenters up
here.
We'd love to take
some questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]